حتى الان
التوازن الطبيه في جنوب تركيا في عصر
الولايات او حتى في او حتى المشافي هناك
التقارير الوارده من هناك حتى الان لا
توجد مشكله في استيعاب هذا العدد من
المرضى لكن هناك مشكله ربما ستظهر في
المستقبل في حال
ازداد العدد بشكل كبير هذه نقطه نقطه اخرى
وجود عدد كبير من السكان في اجواء بارزه
في الشوارع هذا
ايضا هؤلاء بحاجه الى توفير الدعم اللازم
لذلك
حتى لا يكون هناك ضغط على المشافي
الحكوميه او حتى الخاصه التي تستقبل
الجرحى الجرحى نتيجه الزلزال سيكون هناك
مشاكل ميدانيه
ربما ستهتم بموضوع السكان الذين
يبيتون في العراق وبحاجه الى دعم طبي او
نوعا ما رعايه الطبيه ايضا اضافه الى هذا
الميداني ايضا تهتم بجرحى او مصابين حتى
الان لا توجد مشكله
باستيعاب عدد كبير في استيعاب العدد
الحالي لكن الخشيه هي من ازدياد عدد
المصابين بشكل اكبر وايضا
وجود حالات مرضيه بين
الاشخاص الذين يبيتون في العراق او حتى في
اماكن الايواء بما ان درجات الحراره
متدنيه وهذا يؤدي ربما الانتشار الامراض
وايضا الانفلونزا بين السكان خصوصا بين
الاطفال طب زيدان كثير من الدول بالامس
يعني بعد حصول هذه الكارثه اعلنت بانها
سترسل اطقم اغا مساعدات ايضا من
كافه الانواع لتركيا هل بدات تصل هذه
القوافل